this month i am reading every single
chapter of chainsaw men every day i get
sent thousands of requests to cover
different anime and it's always
difficult to choose and it's rarely ever
a manga i mean it stands to reason most
people don't hear about these japanese
stories until their anime gets released
but chainsaw man is very different there
has been so much hype surrounding this
story i don't remember anyone talking
about some japanese property this much
prior to its anime adaptation so it
makes me wonder are we in the presence
of the next big thing or are we dealing
with a flash in the pan fad that will
soon fizzle out as always i don't know
anything about this series prior to
jumping in and so without further ado i
present to you all my blind reactions
and review for the crazy wild and
roaring success story that is tatsuki
fujimoto's chainsaw man
[Music]
okay so this is how this review is gonna
work in total there are 97 chapters that
make up this manga contained within
those 97 chapters are eight individual
story arcs together they make up the
chainsaw man story and today i'll be
covering the first three arcs or first
22 chapters of the manga so let's dive
in the intro arc when i start reading a
new story i look for a few signs or
indicators as i call them to help me
identify the strengths and weaknesses of
a given story with regards to an intro
chapter or arc there is a tremendous
amount of heavy lifting that intro is
required to shoulder what sort of
lifting is required well it largely
depends on the sort of story being told
take attack on titan for example aot is
a story whose strengths reside in the
dramatic grotesque and the mysterious
and due to the attention span of many
readers this opening chapter needed to
be capable of communicating those exact
qualities while simultaneously investing
us into the main cast themselves hajime
isayama achieved this balance through
the character of aaron yeager a
character whose entire being runs
counter to the status quo in this world
and so by getting to know him and his
ambitions we gradually and most
importantly naturally learn about the
broader world of attack on titan its
mysteries and finally the dramatic
threat on the final few pages so does
chainsaw man succeed in executing a
captivating first chapter well let's
have a look broadly speaking the story
of chainsaw man explores the life of her
main character denji a down in his luck
orphan struggling to pay off his
father's debts as a freelance devil
hunter for simplicity's sake devils are
this universe's monsters and he works in
this role alongside his little canine
chainsaw devil friend pochita the rules
of this world are relatively simple with
the only nuance coming by way of
something that's called a contract an
agreement made specifically between a
devil and human resulting in the first
chapter depicting a fusion of denji and
his little devil dog pochita turning
denji into a fiend a hybrid of a human
and devil before being discovered by the
mysterious mahima offering denji a
dilemma die here as a devil by her hand
or work for her and her
government-funded devil hunter agency
and that's the basic outline of the
first chapter unlike attack on titan
drama and mystery take a backseat mostly
in place of a comedic and action-packed
narrative driven largely by its
characters where aot was driven by its
plot and mystery chainsaw man at least
in these opening chapters is driven by
its characters in the same way aaron
facilitated natural chances to show why
his manga was interesting so too does
denji serve his story only in a much
more reactive sense where aaron and aot
was inclined to drive the plot forward
denji by virtue of who he is sort of
goes with the flow while other much
stronger personalities joined the fray
allowing the series to feel much more
like an ensemble cast despite it being
specifically about denji's journey with
that said through his dog effectively
giving up his life to save his only
friend denji becomes motivated to no
longer just talk about his dreams but to
instead take steps to make them a
reality resulting in one of the most
metal and badass transformations i've
seen in quite some time however what's
interesting about this scene to me is
less the transformation and more so
makima's introduction to the series this
girl
scares me she's an oddly cam presence in
what is quite literally a world filled
with monsters introduced at the very end
of the first chapter literally melting
through dengi's more assertive side all
the way through to the vulnerable core
of his character she appears comforting
and exactly what denji thinks he wants
however in reality she's offering him an
ultimatum one that if he chooses
incorrectly could result in his death
here and now as a devil this coupled
with the shadows enshrouding her
character the authority she speaks with
and the fearless and disarming demeanor
she waltzes up to denji with makes for a
very interesting character to say the
least the likes of which are made to
make both us and the denji feel smaller
then and subservient too but that's just
the first chapter the first arc or first
set of chapters are largely centered
around introducing us to the key
recurring characters in the devil
hunting agency denji's joined as well as
his duties day to day the first of these
key characters that i've already touched
on is makima she seems to be a higher up
in this government-funded agency tasked
to take down devils for society and is
on this weird power kick with denji i
will almost definitely touch on later
next is akihakawa denji's handler or
should i say colleague compared to denji
and a certain other character i'll touch
on in just a second he's quite stoic
with a lot more going on right beneath
the surface we've not yet seen much of
he also acts as a vehicle for which
denji can reaffirm his convictions to us
as an audience his dynamic with hayatawa
acts as a convenient mechanism for the
audience to learn more about this world
as denji unaware of the broader details
of his new fiend status and this world's
rules really can ask all the necessary
questions for which aki can answer the
paneling depicting their living
situation and their various interactions
are hilariously handled with page turns
reaction panels and full-blown clean
layouts serving the purpose of
delivering a joke like few i've ever
seen and that's another thing where
dragon ball in one piece got a giggle
out of me here and there chainsaw man
had me literally bursting out in
stitches constantly which let me tell
you never happens however i think this
opening section's strongest narrative
component was its choice to have this
line in chapter three where denji
recognizes that his life isn't going to
be worth much if he's already achieved
his goal of getting off the streets and
eating relatively well he sees people
like hayakawa driven by retribution
makima driven by
[Music]
this is denji's new goal my friends and
this is where a new character called
power comes screaming into the story
[Music]
power is the perfect yin to denji's yang
while also sharing so many things in
common with him and her introductory
story with the group is on its face
utterly silly with denji effectively
trying to win power's favor to touch her
chest however what spawns from this is
oddly and surprisingly brilliant however
before i talk about all of that i need
to talk about tatsuki fujimoto's
character designs because wow are these
brilliant designs when one starts
designing a character one of the most
important aspects to keep in mind is how
this design will serve to communicate to
a reader who this character is just at a
glance denji as a character is quite
unassuming and simple and his character
design reflects that very reality hajime
izayama took a very similar approach
with aaron jaeger in attack on titan by
drawing him in a rather unremarkable and
almost forgettable fashion the point of
erin jaeger early on is to point out
that he isn't remarkable and the same is
true for chainsaw man's denji in this
instance furthermore and again like
aaron yeager dengy's transformed state
is enhanced to look even more impressive
simply by comparison to his base form
think magikarp and gyarados gyarados
looks impressive already but when you
look at magikarp next to it suddenly it
looks all the more monstrous and where
aaron in attack on titan enhances his
titan forms intimidation factor one
could say that chainsaw man utilizes and
leans into this very visual trick a lot
more effectively brandishing a meek and
shrinking posture wearing a large amount
of white with rounded almost quivering
shapes and lines used to convey his soft
nervous human side denji's physical form
stands in stark contrast with the
violent jagged and exaggerated shapes
that coat this comic's pages in the
blood of its enemies in every sense of
the word this design is one built on the
back of contrasts contrasts that
communicate a distinct shift in how this
character engages with the world around
him whether it be exaggerated instances
like those in which he fully transforms
or even the crooked smiles he shares
when something more is on his mind denji
looks like a regular almost forgettable
looking person in the world when nothing
is driving him however when something
does or he's motivated in a particular
direction he starts to reveal a set of
sharp and potentially dangerous teeth
perhaps implying that right beneath this
unassuming facade lies the power of a
true devil but that's just dengy someone
like hayakawa on the other hand is
almost the exact opposite and seems to
be wound quite tight and i think partly
this is what makes his dynamic with
dengue so interesting while denji's
outward appearance is consistently messy
hayakawa always has his hair tied up
purposefully all the while he wears a
much more complete dark uniform symbolic
of his devotion to the job he has and
perhaps hinting towards a darker
backstory driving him forwards and
finally let's talk about power the
character of power speaks to this
philosophy directly the moment we meet
power she is over the top loud and
swinging her fist in the air a big
personality with an appearance that
communicates that very aspect of her
character through her clothes and devil
traits being much more obvious on her
than on denji's character design whether
it be her disheveled hair half tucked in
shirt jagged teeth horns or her eyes
bearing a striking resemblance to that
of a crosshairs on a gun power comes
across as a boisterous mischievous and
active character to team up with our
less driven and thus far comparatively
passive main character in denji creating
this wonderful kinetic push and pull
dynamic which leads us nicely into the
second and really the first major arc of
this story
the bat devil arc this is the arc where
we finally begin to get a handle on the
main through line of the story and the
potentially sinister nature that lurks
beneath its pages while a shallow
observation of this arc might lead you
to believe it's a simple noble quest a
young man goes on to earn power's favor
it is in fact a story about complicated
themes of manipulation trust and other
things in interviews fujimoto has
revealed that a main inspiration behind
the character of power came by way of
south park's eric cartman and you can
absolutely see that in her introductory
sequence she's chaotic abrasive and most
importantly
active making her a terrific addition to
denji's already reactive personality
creating moments for him to react to and
indeed for us to learn more about the
story in chapter 5 following power's
introduction and subsequent professional
mistake both her and denji begin to
argue as makima cuts them off
immediately power stops shouting and
listens mahima says good girl power i
want to see big things from you and with
that very lion's completion fujimoto
brings us in for an uncomfortably
intimate close-up on makima's almost
hypnotic eye as she continues
do you think you can show me that
immediately power responds sweating uh
i'll show you this is the only
indication that something more is going
on with makima and absolutely put her on
my watch list while the rest of the
story unfolded makima is giving me mixed
vibes and signals on one hand she seems
to be held in really high regard by
pretty much everyone including aki who i
don't have a reason not to trust yet but
on the other hand she treats both denji
and power
like dogs and in response to this
supposed coercion once power learns what
denji wants she leverages that so she
can achieve her ends power wants her cat
back from this devil holding it hostage
and denji wants the goods each
individual has something the other can
potentially fulfill and therein lies the
motivation and dynamic for this short
arcs hijinx and boy does it look amazing
concerning artwork when i read the story
of one piece i loved it for its depth of
lore character and at times profound
introspection its accuracy when
dissecting the human condition through a
cavalcade of warm and fiendish
characters with chainsaw man i love it
almost as much for what amounts to
practically the exact opposite reason in
this arc i've made this argument before
much to the chagrin of the one piece
fandom but at times particularly towards
the second half of that series while oda
produces some outstanding artwork i
think he leaves a lot to be desired when
it comes to constructing and composing
his page layouts to a certain extent and
it's obviously not because he lacks the
ability he's one of the greatest to have
ever picked up the pen but what i do
think is that the depth of lore and
nuance that one piece is famous for and
he's required to convey in such a short
span of time hinders how that
information is presented sometimes in
his manga chainsaw man in every single
arc i've covered so far does not have
this problem for me and i think it's
down to how in a sense simple fujimoto
has decided to keep his plotlines at
least as we understand them right now
how many points of view or groups are we
following in this story just one really
denji and power patrolling the area and
looking for her lost cat there's maybe a
second point of view if you want to
include makima's meeting with the
sinister board of definitely evil
characters but in reality there's one
point of view and gold to follow
throughout this arc with the nuance not
coming from the multiple converging
plotlines but in fact the overall
message of the story and its characters
and thanks to this fujimoto is never
really in a rush to communicate anything
to us if he wants to show two colleagues
sitting in a boss with nothing to talk
about he will if he wants to show an
awkward interaction for the sake of a
joke he will more than happily sacrifice
many pages to bring that vision to life
and due to this the result isn't
something you need to study feverishly
there's rarely ever a single moment
where you'll turn the page and think wow
that sure is a lot of text i sure hope i
hold on to all of this information here
and for that i'm honestly supremely
thankful when i see a cluttered page
layout during a dramatic or comedic
scene i see a page at odds with what the
narrative or that scene is trying to
achieve layouts cannot make a bad story
great but bad layouts can absolutely
make a great story irritating and
lethargic and so chainsaw men because of
its approach makes exceptional use of
space expression and panel structure
which in turn enhances the humor drama
and ultimately the horror of this story
the fight that ensues has some brilliant
action shots that look [ __ ] awesome
helped tremendously by facilitating some
great character-defining moments for
denji where he decides to show his
desire to protect people and other
moments where he chooses to be more
reckless and while the fight is great
it's the latter part of that which makes
this story blossom for me particularly
when it comes to power and denji's
relationship this is the confrontation
where denji proves to power that he's
someone worthy of further consideration
unlike denji power is categorized by
everyone including herself as someone
very different to denji and other humans
countless times she points out emotional
problems she sees with the way denji and
other humans express themselves this
cold way of seeing the world is chalked
up to her being a fiend by others and
even us until we see her internal
feelings concerning her beloved cat
having lured and ambushed denji into
this bat devil's lair to sacrifice him
and rescue her cat she herself gets
double crossed and in the process eat
and while dingy finds new reserves of
boob inspired strength we as an audience
dive deep into who she is as a character
and we learn that while she is quite
disconnected she is capable of feeling
an appreciation and fondness for
something more than her own well-being
which brings us to
the reward
there are lots of comparisons made to
dogs and puppies in the story with
regards to those that work beneath
makima in her organization on top of
being referred to as such they share a
kennel they are punished as a group and
are incentivized with treats and without
an ounce of hyperbola this chapter
entitled squeeze is kind of interesting
for reasons that are totally unrelated
to the intimate nature of the squeezes
that take place within as i mentioned
towards the beginning of this review
denji comes from a life of virtually
nothing and as if like a stray dog
picked up by makima's animal control he
quickly tries to find a goal to latch
onto a dream to help him feel like part
of the group like part of the team to
feel like his life is worthwhile for his
little dog's sacrifice and while this
initial motivation is played for laughs
on a number of occasions that by the way
worked to great effect surprisingly it's
denji's reaction to his reaching of this
goal that's quite interesting with
regards to his reward from power he
feels nothing he feels hollow certainly
not the triumphant victory a typical
shonen protagonist would enjoy sitting
dejected uncertain as to whether or not
he could face reaching for another dream
out of fear of it being massively
disappointing yet again makima out of
literally nowhere fulfills this fantasy
of his and when she does
it's everything he dreamt it would be
and more
[Music]
there's a lot to unpack here within
chapter 12 there are two scenes really
two scenes that contrast heavily in
terms of tone and fujimoto wants us to
notice this shift in tone through the
words exchanged the expression shared
and indeed the framing of the two scenes
in this chapter the framing now takes
the driving seat in communicating to us
how we should understand and interpret
this story with the scene denji shares
with power in the bathroom it's framed
in a much more conventional manner as
the rest of the series bright with a few
gags and a twist at the end roll credits
right well it would be if not for the
next scene with makima for when she
shares her scene with denji everything
suddenly feels a lot more
intimate and sinister
shadows grip the pages everything that
happens is entirely by surprise or out
of control and most importantly there's
a change in physical level that reflects
that emotional reality where denji stood
above power during their scene in
makima's it's the exact opposite she
looms over his shoulder standing next to
him at first while he sits and when he
falls to the floor this divide in how
they perceive each other is embellished
and emphasized makima is powerful and in
control treating denji like a dog she's
training and just like with any new
puppy you reward good behavior with
treats
that way they understand who the master
truly is
in response to this interaction with
power it was honest and platonic through
their combined journey in this arc they
form a much more tangible and mutually
beneficial relationship with makimas she
further manipulates denji into accepting
a tremendously dangerous mission to find
and apprehend a villain that's eluded
her and her agency
for years
the gun devil
ladies and gentlemen this is our main
narrative through life
[Music]
the eternity devil arc if denji can kill
the gun devil then she will grant him
any wish he wants these are the
parameters set on the very first page of
this very arc and through them we have
our next adventure and before i talk
about the story itself i want to talk
about something i read in preparation
for this review series a one-shot manga
entitled look back released in 2021 by
tatsuki fujimoto himself and within this
it drew my attention to something
fujimoro does tremendously well
something i noticed in that one shot and
in this very arc numerous times that
being a shocking and sudden twist of
events sometimes in storytelling there's
an indication that something big will
happen soon where the author alludes to
something approaching on horizon subtly
or explicitly in any case this can be
compared to hitchcock's famous bomb
under the table narrative technique
where one to varying degrees lets the
readers know there's a metaphorical bomb
under the table turning a given scene
into a great mechanism for building
tension however as it happens fujimoto
foregoes such warnings in favor of
something that will completely take you
by surprise in this arc fujimoto begins
to show us a flashback of a family it's
filled with enough detail and its very
own narrative to allow it to stand on
its own two feet we follow the story
eagerly awaiting a resolution that's
being built up to and
then we're reminded that this was a
story detailing the gun devil's origin
impressing unto us in a much more
visceral fashion just how sudden and
devastating this disaster was and i
think what i love about this technique
is that it's so versatile fujimoto uses
this very technique in look back to
create a powerful sense of loss and
emotional outburst right here in this
arc he uses it to impress upon us the
severity of the occasion and later in
the story he'll use it again to change
the entire narrative however before we
dive into this story properly an
interesting wrinkle this story has added
to its combat and magic system is that
of fear fear collective or personal
seems to play a role in the strength or
effectiveness of a given devil's power
this is why the sea cucumber devil was
very weak and it's why the gun devil was
so powerful furthermore it perhaps
indirectly tells us a bit about makima
she wants the gun devil taken out and to
do so she employs the help of the
chainsaw devil a devil no doubt many
would be fearful of and perhaps the more
notorious his devil power becomes the
more powerful he'll end up becoming and
perhaps this explains makima's first
interaction with denji perhaps she
showed zero fear embracing him
entrancing him as a powerful means of
disarming the fear that feeds this
devil's respective powers but that's
just a theory right now in this moment
we have another goal find the gun devil
and they have a means to do so too
following the attacks that took place
wiping out millions of people across the
world on behalf of the gun devil certain
parts of the gun devil have been found
in different bodies of different devils
and once enough parts are gathered they
start to be drawn to the gun devil
itself simple effective and within that
framework there's tons of flexibility so
how does fujimoto proceed by setting up
a narrative technique i adore in
long-running tv shows and movies the
bottle episode in these situations the
director or in this case author takes
the established cast and places them
into a finite space for the majority or
the entire duration of the story i love
this because we no longer need context
clues or establishing shots instead we
can focus on continuous scenes filled
with opportunities for interesting
character retrospectives and in the case
of chainsaw men gags following the trail
of the gun devil denji aki power and
three new characters himeno kobenai and
arai following the slaughter of a single
weird-looking devil in the building find
themselves trapped on the eighth floor
they can't go up or down the stairs they
can't go through the ceilings and the
windows all lead back to the eighth
floor it's like they're stuck in their
own little parallel universe or wormhole
dimension i love this this is the third
arc of this series and while each arc
ends with a big battle between chainsaw
man denji and insert monster here each
encounter feels so very different from
each other the first one in the
introductory arc facilitates our
introduction to the world and its rules
the second one with the bat devil served
to introduce us to different characters
and this one very much shows us how the
chainsaw devil powers work in greater
detail all the while allowing us to form
much more deeper connections to the
likes of aki whose backstory we see
ximena who provides the stakes for denji
in this arc with a kiss to motivate him
or power who provided me with more betty
laughs than any other manga i've read in
the past the third page from chapter 16
in particular is brilliant the devil
they face in this arc is super fun to
work with particularly when we take into
consideration the fear that they're
feeling is contributing to the dwindling
amount of space that they have left in
the area they reside no food no water
it's a dire set of circumstances that
all point in one direction fear and one
that has aki teasing that he'll use some
sword in his possession i still have no
idea what that is by the way as time
pushes on where the tension reaches a
boiling point with dissension rife
amongst the group until dengi steps up
to the plate and chainsaws this monster
to kingdom come for literally days and
days on end until it finally just gives
up out of pain drinking his blood in the
process to fuel his attacks however i'd
be lying if i said that this was the
part of the arc people remember or that
i have stuck in my head like the prior
arc the conflict wasn't the focus but
instead the rewards and resolutions
following the demonstration himeno and
the rest of the group go out for drinks
together in celebration makima is
supposed to attend to this get-together
and she does so drinking a hell of a lot
more than pretty much anyone else at the
table however something happens ximena
is drunk she promised denji a tonkis and
what denji gets is not that instead
fujimoto decides to draw one of the most
legendary panels i've ever seen ladies
and gentlemen
behold art is meant to make you feel
something and
that something can be anger joy lust or
really anything
and this piece this piece right here
that you're looking at that i'm making
you look at for longer than you might be
comfortable with this made me feel
something deep in my stomach
she wants to go further however denji
recalls the promise he made to makima a
promise that stops him from accepting
himeno's drunken proposal the following
morning denji is awoken by ximena's
friendly face and breakfast they then
resolve to help each other out in
connecting with who they each like and
then fujimoto cuts to the next page once
again making use of the very technique i
touched on earlier to say that i was
absolutely surprised shocked and
horrified
would be an understatement i have quite
literally no idea now where this story
will take me by the time i finished
reading this arc i felt myself thinking
this more so than any other story i've
read in the past feels like a brilliant
and almost natural evolution on the
standard set by one piece and before
that dragon ball this feels like
something entirely fresh and new and i
don't really understand how best else to
express that feeling it manages to be
one of the easiest mangas i've ever read
with tremendously interesting
compositions and page layouts just like
dragon ball all the while presenting
very real and human characters i can
consider the interpersonal relationships
and intentions of like one piece this is
of course not to say that this story is
remotely like any of these properties
however the strengths that make these
stories stand out for me i feel were
inspirations for chainsaw men tatsuki
fujimoto is the youngest mangaka i've
ever covered on this channel and in
addition to that the only creator i've
ever covered that's younger than me at
28 years of age he comes from the
generation of children that grew up with
stories like one piece and naruto and he
says as much in interviews and speaking
of interviews in an interview conducted
in 2017 around the time he completed the
story of his previous series fire punch
fujimoto was asked if he considers the
reception his stories received much from
the public and to that he said
i don't think about it that much i think
my readers have read a lot of manga and
have gotten bored later in the interview
he goes on to say with the internet you
can only find what you're looking for i
like horror so i look up things about
horror but
that's totally unnecessary
you have to stray from the path if you
want to go anywhere covered clear and
obvious homages to western ideas like
zombies and stories like the texas
chainsaw massacre which fujimoto tells
us that he really likes a lot on the
very first page of the second volume
however despite taking inspiration from
these properties and ideas he's managed
to fearlessly go against the grain and
traditional story structures in many
ways and in doing so managed to create a
story that is unlike anything i've read
and now much like when i was a kid
eagerly awaiting the next episode of
dragon ball at 30 years old for the very
first time in years i am genuinely and
excitedly thumping away at my keyboard
to finish this script so i can continue
reading this remarkably fresh and
enjoyable series i hope you'll join me
on the rest of this adventure as i
tackle more of this story each week but
until then i've been told that mark i
can't wait to read more chainsaw man i
hope you enjoyed this video and i'll see
you all next time
take care
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]